a close look under the hood of the Skoda
reveals a manipulated diesel engine
according to owner Johannes Eagle the
Skoda brand belongs to Volkswagen which
Eagle says has not even informed him of
the problem VW is paying out billions in
compensation to owners in the US but not
in Germany or elsewhere in Europe there
the car maker is only offered to repair
the manipulated engines sharpish zort
dear Martha why we're so angered by VW
manipulating its cars but I told myself
they just can't get away with this can
you sign does he damn it garfunkel Eagle
found a lawyer through the my right web
portal which invites affected VW owners
to sue Volkswagen as a group what's
known in other countries as a class
action suit plaintiffs don't pay
anything but thirty percent of the
compensation would go to the
hamburg-based portal ya mook listening
mid viene al fund and we give customers
a chance to make their voices heard
without all the hassle of finding a
lawyer which is expensive and going to
court where it takes weeks to get an
appointment then they have to appear
before a judge which a lot of customers
are reluctant to do Sarah shine fear in
[ __ ] matter its tongue stay the web
portal hired an expensive lawyer in
Berlin he says German customers should
be entitled to compensation even if
volkswagen has been claiming otherwise
and dodge hunt moose angle of Germany an
expert has to estimate the loss and
resale value and calculate the
additional operating costs of the
affected vehicle just like all the other
volkswagen customers who were cheated
mystery girl here has a fundamental
claim for compensation guitar stagg
Volkswagen Clinton and unch poor of in
chittagong
so far though volkswagen has refused to
compensate customers in germany it'd
probably be unfair if one person's
getting compensation everyone true
happiness let's assume in Germany has a
different legal system than in the US
and there's nothing wrong with that it
is unfair in principle but our system
works differently in Germany so I think
it's okay in the long run if you think
it was someone's life can suck it the
Cantonian Scott is no criminal law for
corporations in Germany so what do you
expect Johannes eagle is counting on
four thousand euros in compensation it's
too early to say if the group lawsuit
will go through but tens of thousands of
VW owners have already signed up
you